Hello world,
it's Saroj and what hyper parameters
should you use to train your model?
You'll see these magic numbers a lot.
They are the model values that are
set before you train on any dataset.
An ML model.
It's just a formula with a number of
parameters that need to be learned from
data,
but there are also parameters that can't
be directly learned from the regular
training process,
and we call these higher level properties,
hyper parameters. This could be the
number of trees in a random forest,
the number of hidden
layers in a neural network,
the learning rate for logistic regression.
It's a process of trial and error
and it's not very intuitive.
Since we're not great at
interpreting high dimensional data,
legendary researchers like Oriole Vinyasa,
Ilya Sutskever,
consider the possibility space
of hyper parameters there canvas.
But what if we could have these
parameters learn the optimal values for
themselves that would make life easier,
right?
Let's see if we can figure out a really
basic strategy for ourselves and then
try to improve it.
I've got a Dataset here of tweets
that are labeled as either positive or
negative perfect for a binary
classification problem,
and let's say I built a support vector
machine to learn this mapping so it can
then classify a new tweet immediately.
This is called sentiment analysis and
it's a really popular task in NLP.
If we mapped out these
vectors in two d space,
we could imagine a curvy line that
separates the positive tweets from the
negative ones, a decision boundary
separate but equal weight.
That's something else.
A support vector machine can help
us define this decision barrier.
Since it's nonlinear, our SVM will
use what's known as the kernel trick.
That means instead of trying
to fit a nonlinear model,
we can map the data from the input
space to a new higher dimensional space
called the feature space
by doing a nonlinear
transformation using a colonel or
similarity function and then use a
linear model. In the feature space,
we define our kernel or
similarity function between
tweak vectors as the radial
basis function,
which takes as input to vectors
and outputs a similarity
based on the following
function. So the more similar two tweets
are the higher the output value from our
function.
There are two hyper parameters that
govern how our line is going to be drawn.
Both of these hyper parameters
need to be selected very carefully.
They depend on each other in unknown ways,
so we can't just optimize one parameter
at a time. Then combine the result.
What if we just tried every
single possible combination
of hyper parameters to
brute force?
Assuming we've built our sem already,
we can choose a set of possible values
for both of them and create a variable to
store our model's accuracy for each set.
Then we'll create a nested
for loop for every value of c,
try every value of gamma inside our loop.
We'll initialize our SVM with the
hyper parameters at that iteration.
We'll train it and score it,
then compare its score to our best score.
If it's better,
we'll update our values accordingly.
This process will run for every hyper
parameter value we have until it finds the
optimal ones.
This technique is called grid search
because we've essentially made a grid of
our search space and then evaluated each
hyper parameter setting at the points
we've introduced for as many
dimensions as necessary.
This was a pretty easy
strategy to implement,
but this scales pretty poorly.
The more hyper parameters
or dimensions we add,
also known as the curse of dimensionality,
I think we can do better
than an exhaustive search.
We tried every combination of a preset
list of values of our hyper parameters,
but what if instead we tried random
combinations of a range of values for a
number of iterations we define this
won't guarantee that we'll get the best
hyper parameter combination
like grid search did,
but it will take a lot less time.
So manual search,
grid search and random search
are all fine and dandy,
but there's gotta be a more intelligent
way of doing this that incorporates
learning.
One technique that's very popular right
now is called Bayesian optimization.
Last episode we talked about how base
theorem is a way to determine conditional
probability.
It shows us how to update an existing
prediction given new evidence.
This forms the basis of the Bayesian
way of thinking as opposed to the
frequentist way of thinking.
These are the two different
approaches to probability.
Basically it's like a mathematical
gang war between applied statisticians.
How's it the cash? And Phil was my choices
that keep it objective. I'm selecting,
it's all about the gear.
Bayesean
means probabilistic.
It focuses on the probability of
the hypothesis given the data.
That means the data is fixed
and the hypothesis is random.
The frequentist approach focuses on
the probability of the data given the
hypothesis. So data is random
as in if we repeat the study,
that data might come out differently,
but the hypothesis is fixed.
We could apply frequentist or Bayesian
methods to pretty much any learning
algorithm.
They have different aims in the context
of hyper parameter optimization. Uh,
Basie and approach takes advantage of
the information our model learns during
the optimization process.
The idea is that we pick some prior
belief about how our hyper parameters will
behave and then search the perimeter
space by enforcing and updating our prior
belief based on our ongoing measurement.
So the trade off between exploration,
making sure we visited the relevant
corners of our space and exploitation.
Once we found the promising
region of our space.
Finding an optimal value in it is
handled in a more intelligent way.
No, we only have few weeks left
with mid serial last model.
I know eventually we'll find
the right hyper parameters,
but how we tried to frequent this
approach and it didn't work. I know,
but we could try the Bayesean. Oh, so we
can bank on certain in our mobile itself,
like random variable.
Exactly. A lot of people are,
the models are using it these days.
Let's go ahead.
Basie and optimization uses previously
evaluated points to compute a posterior
expectation of what the loss f looks like.
Then it samples a loss at a new point
that maximizes some utility of the
expectation of f.
That utility tells us which regions of
the domain of f our best to sample from
this two step process is
repeated until convergence.
For the prior distribution.
We assume that F can be
described by a golf Sian process.
A gaussian distribution often called a
normal distribution is described as a
bell shaped curve.
Distributions are equations that will
link outcomes of a statistical experiment
with its probability of occurring.
The Gospel, Ian is quite popular.
Half the data falls on the left of the
mean half falls on the right and this is
useful in many situations.
A Goss IOM process is a generation of
the golf Sian distribution over functions
instead of random variables.
So wild gosh in distributions
are specified by their
mean and variance Gaussian
processes are specified by their main
function and covariance function.
The way we find the best point to sample
f next from is to pick the point that
maximizes an acquisition function.
This is a function of the posterior
distribution over f that describes the
utility for all values
of the hyper parameters.
The values that have the highest utility
will be the values we compute the Los
four next,
we'll use the popular expected improvement
function where x is the current
optimal set of hyper parameters.
By maximizing this,
it will give us the point
that improves on f the most.
So given the observed values f of x,
we update the posterior expectation
of f using the GP model.
Then we find that the new acts that
maximizes the acquisition function,
the expected improvement,
and finally compute the
value of f for the new X.
Initially the algorithm will
explore the parameter space,
but it quickly discovers the region with
best performance and samples points in
that region. Much smarter
strategy, right? To summarize,
we can optimize our hyper
parameters using several strategies,
but Basie and optimization
looks most promising.
Bayesean optimization picks a prior
belief about how the hyper parameters will
behave and then searches the parameter
space by enforcing an updating that prior
belief based on ongoing measurements.
So Bayesians let their prior beliefs
influenced their predictions.
Frequent tests don't.
And now to announce the real heroes,
the wizards of the week
is Noah [inaudible].
Noah built a naive Bayes classifier to
distinguish rap lyrics from biggie and
Tupac.
He uses unigrams,
bigrams and trigrams to count words and
achieve the best results with unigrams.
Great work.
Noah and the runner up is Hammad shake
his naive Bayes classifier detected spam
and youtube comments.
And he's a popular TF IDF technique to
determine how important and word was
instead of bag of words.
Next level,
this week's coding challenge is to write
out a Bayesean optimization strategy
for the hyper parameters of
a linear regression model.
See the get hub link in the description
for instructions and poster,
get hub link in the comment section.
I'll announce a winner next week.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos,
and for now I've got to update my priors,
so thanks for watching.